welcome to this video playing the cross
shark here from the UK let's see what
kind of way we get ok let's go for my my
old my old line at least I'm reasonably
quick playing this this variation even
though I tend to get in trouble yeah
Bishop h6 this is surprisingly often
played I think it's just a lot of a
temple but ok mmm because night f7 you
have to retreat the bishop pretty much
you have to retreat it taking on g7
gives me long-term chances on the dark
squares sorry not a good idea ok so i
can take on c4 i can shut the whole
thing down ok I'm shutting it down yeah
leading to a super close position
okay he's out our two tribe f4 maybe
Luke beard looks mysterious I know I
want to go 98 Bishop f8 Bishop to age
six and trading off my slightly bad
bishop okay I can this is this is always
a tricky thing if you want to take there
or not but I value the Knights quite
highly in this position let's make it
bishop age six and I should be okay okay
I'm taking and putting this on e5 so
let's see how do i fly maybe look to f7
here
oh it's a surprising solution I his he's
out to go for Queen chiffon hmm
interesting
hmm
how do I want to play h5 here I don't
know that set can be can easily blow up
to my face but allowing something to g4
is also a bit of a bit of a risky
proposition ok so I'm going here for
Queen d8 in case of Quincy 5mm struggles
I forgot a totally totally miss that
idea that's pretty strong
very strong green g8 look f7 Bishop g5
is this a line no it's not but I can
play look at 8i guess if I can get one
look traded I'm probably okay okay fade
I'm sure if I'm missing something well
if I get one look traded i'm okay i
believe
no it might hold yeah I know why okay I
don't want to play this line anymore but
it's really like a bad habit and usually
my my results are not that bad sometimes
have those kind of crappy positions but
I quite often tend to score with them
yeah I am this is this is already
shaping up he's doing something that I
think he'd should not do and I have some
play now on the f are so H for or not
not sure I look F form Bishop age for
now this is maybe an idea putting this
on an active spot okay I can take and
take them check I mean they're means
here on g4 now maybe queen here for
Bishop g5 yeah yeah I'm a bit more
comfortable now just a little bit
nothing serious but the night has to be
activated to f6 ideally I can always fly
queen e r3 and just draw probably it's
probably just a drawn at least it's the
drive i'm trading queens maybe i can go
here and then like King g7 Knight f6
yeah i can activate the night this is a
better better choice it's a bit more
interesting and Knight to f6 my king is
a bit safe for him
out for night age 7 and Knight to g5
Bishop to e3 here we go wait he wants to
go to age 30 I guess I can go to h4
though mix it not so it's not so easy
for him now to move this pieces so
Knight f6 I guess or what is he doing
then maybe maybe here actually and then
queen of two hmm now hg5 is probably not
enough cannot go Queenie 112 kind of
nonsense I'm a highly talking here now
to deform or onto f4i go to f4 takes
takes a five I have to check on g3 it's
a bit tricky but interesting ok
try to reroute the night over to g6 now
yeah probably if a trade Queens it's a
draw the risky thing is 30 seconds this
would be a dream position to play with
increment because you can shuffle around
for ages and torch em
going for Queen at four if possible
22 now in the in the mix Jack and that's
it at least position-wise timewise I
don't know it is the kind of game that
keeps me lets me play this thing because
I sometimes check really do good things
in this crappy looking positions I'm
good in those in those strange
maneuvering kind of scenarios white
resigns yeah I was one of a kind of a
model came for that kind of weathering
the storm and waiting basically waiting
for him to do something something bad
but yeah it's not really a good good
line okay so h5 I wanted to prevent
something to deform and here that looks
dangerous ok the computer points out
wide win actually night at five yeah
it's difficult to foresee something like
that as black and for white yeah the
point is that here here this is a
winning attack Bishop comes here yeah
yeah I didn't see that one at all now I
think I'm probably kind of okay yeah I
get ropes off and this rock off I don't
think it's a good idea to keep this on
and G form we consist dark squares yeah
starting from here I'm a bit more I'm a
bit more comfortable and yeah here I
actually had more time yeah I keep spent
too much time off
yeah I think I did a good job in holding
the whole thing keeping Queens on and
now now it gets tricky Bishop nd2 Bishop
see one is even better yeah Bishop t2
fancy moves syndrome this is even
stronger black wins here funny enough he
is out of his out of moves okay Queen f4
is invasion time and this is a funny
line given by the engine and & zukes one
zoosk one check check winning in the
house yeah funny I got a got a nice win
in there from my from my will term be a
bad habit line in the children right
okay when is the win thanks for watching